[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bougent froid bouffe
fois aux patrons le vieux bob très belle
north ma petite fiole
[Musique]
prolonger mon
à l'eau sur la terre
comme au pont de vaux répond
[Musique]
que tu qu'après
barda les garçons âme d enfant depuis
n'ai pas peur monsieur
du colloque aux promeneurs un criminel
bonsoir à prouilly ça
que je postule ou le long
avait
au secours va voir ce qui ce passe ma
petite pas prennent elles je crois qu'on
t'a plu
[Musique]
à l'eau
okubo tu proposes libre
[Musique]
je vis la colonie d'abris voilà abuse
pas vu à temps un peu aux bonnes
et wittes il se fit l'un aux
mains d acheter ou louer ou ou au
secours
[Musique]
courage moors attrape le voilà j veu
voulais me voilà
où salle aux
petits comme aux levées dans votre
foulard
quand je vois le bout de votre nez
prenez un peu ici mais le petit cowboy
laisse la petite up à croquer annoncé la
bouche et
gérant
rené north
optique autant tu as voulu me faire peur
tu vas voir tu vas la prochaine fois
c'est moi qui te ferait blog
[Rires]
pour partager à la boîte de nuit petit
drôle
[Musique]
alors courage nounours on s'est bien
amusés patron ce que jury
tu n'as pas eu peur moi bord
allons en route ayrault bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher on
brassait de l'info par eau et feu de
pour eux
[Musique]
oh